Storytelling is so important
for the human experience.
Storytelling is a way to live hundreds
and thousands of lives in our lifetime.
What I think is meaningful
about what we do is,
I can tell you a story that acknowledges
you as a human being a little bit,
and you take my worldview
with you when you walk out.
We both get something
out of that, in a beautiful way.
What I think is really powerful
about long-form storytelling
is that you can really dig deeper
and excavate and unfold things
that enrich the whole story
But there’s always the fear
that you’ll never get to finish it,
never get to tell the end of the story.
I think that’s one of the things
that scared me the most
about going into long-form television.
-Here we go.
-And background.
And action!
It’s five hours of material every year.
That’s two and a half movies.
It takes me two years to make one film.
And cut! Excellent.
I’m so grateful
that we had this opportunity
and that we got to finish the story.
Beautiful.
When we started it, we knew the premise
and we knew the two storylines,
but we really didn’t know
where it was going to go.
And then, by the end of that first season,
it started to become clear.
Do you know who you welcomed
into your home?
When the pandemic hiatused us,
it was a real moment, that was kind of
beautiful, for me to sit down and go,
“Okay, these are all the different
ideas that we have.
How many seasons is that?
How many episodes is that?”
That was how it kind of came
to be a four-season show.
You're getting more clarity.
My name is Leanne Grayson,
and I come from Wisconsin.
One of the fun ideas for the show
was telling the origin story of Leanne.
It can be interpreted in two ways.
Is this the story of a fallen angel,
embodied now in this young girl?
As she embraces this,
does she become this dark entity
that could really change
the balance of everything?
Or is this just a girl
that has these delusions,
and maybe there’s a grounded explanation?
Why would she put
her own baby in your crib?
Both explanations are plausible.
That’s a fun story that we wanted to tell.
Ah!
One of the hopes
when I hired Nell Tiger Free
was that we would watch this young girl
grow into a woman
over the course of the show.
And then,
when we get to the final season,
she would be a formidable presence.
Do you think I’m scary?
What about now?
I love that architecture for her.
Ultimately, what drew her
to this house is Dorothy.
She’s just in awe of Dorothy.
Her need for Dorothy to accept her,
and love her, is primal.
It’s a mother figure that she never had.
Shhh. Shh. Shh.
At first, it was longing
and doing the childlike things
but then getting more physical.
She’s so tired of feeling bad,
and feeling wrong,
and feeling like she isn’t good enough.
Which is all the dynamics
from her real mom.
She’s started to feel it again
with this family,
and she’s not going to have it.
You should all be very careful.
Now she sees the fear in their eyes.
She likes this feeling.
She starts to get to the premise of,
"I need to get everything
out of this house
except for me and Dorothy
and this child."
I’m never gonna let you
back in this house.
Eventually, Dorothy will come to see
that this is a good thing.
That’s her fantasy.
She’s going to do everything possible
to make that happen.
It’s just you and me now.
Just let me take my child and leave!
Jericho has always been the embodiment
of love, and fragility and vulnerability,
that represents all of our hopes
and fears when we have a kid,
and whether we’re going to fail
or succeed in protecting them.
And the helplessness that we all feel.
That’s so scary.
Whenever we see Jericho as he’s moving
through the developmental stages,
like his birthday,
and he’s learning to eat,
each of these things.
This is the treasure
that’s being given this family.
Every time they hold him, it feels
like it’s worth it, whatever the cost is.
Servant is about a woman
who’s forgotten that she was responsible
for her child’s death,
and the ticking clock
about when she’s going to remember.
That’s why I did this show.
I wanted to get to that episode.
Her story was so important.
I wanted to direct
her descent into madness,
and I wanted to direct
the moment she woke up.
Ahhhhh!
We’re all fighting not to have
that painful moment,
but the irony is, that’s exactly
the moment we should all be running to.
It was a freak accident.
The thing that we’re scared to say,
for fear that,
"I don’t know what’s going
to happen on the other side."
That’s very much human nature.
I always try to put myself in the mindset
of the characters and say,
"Would I do this?”
There is no higher stakes
than losing your child,
having the person you love
disappear in front of your eyes.
I would probably do anything
to get back what I had lost.
Sean has made a Faustian bargain,
and realizes that
there’s no way out of this.
You’ve already made your choice.
So be an adult and deal
with the consequences.
It’s coming at a cost, and the cost is,
he doesn’t get to talk about
what happened to them and the loss.
You should have been there, Julian.
She called you!
But we’re not ready
to talk about that, are we?
And we’ll never be ready,
because you can’t handle real life.
One inconvenience,
and you fall off the wagon.
Julian is an addict,
and keeps on doing forms of addiction,
whether it’s drugs or materialism.
He’ll do anything to escape
the feeling of guilt and trauma
that has associated with the events
that happened to this family.
Sean!
Julian!
There’s a pretty dark moment
where Sean and Julian
come to the realization
that this girl has to leave this house.
We’re going to stop being polite.
We may have to cross the line here.
Hello, Leanne.
It’s shocking to all of them.
They’re questioning themselves.
Wow, when we’re fighting for our family,
we are willing to hurt someone else.
That’s what scary about having
a darker presence near you.
You start to take on
all of their value systems.
They're like, “See, you’d do anything,
too, to get what you want.”
I’m so sorry for what we did to you.
It is primarily these four actors,
constantly interacting
for these 40 episodes.
It is a play, essentially.
They were game for what I was
asking them to do, which is,
“Hey, we’re going to push
the artistic mediums.
We’re going to shoot
these things in unusual ways,
and sometimes it’s not going to work,
but we’re going to keep pushing it.”
And they were so open to risk themselves,
rather than play it safe.
I think they found it exciting
to be risking themselves
in that way for those 40 episodes.
I’m prepared to do whatever it takes
to get rid of Leanne.
The biblical story that we’re telling
is being manifested
in physical form in the house.
The house has always been
a reflection of the family.
As the house is deteriorating,
it’s almost like
you’re in your own nightmare,
and you start to sense
that this is not sustainable.
Now, this has escalated to the point
that we’re on the cusp
of something catastrophic.
If she wins, the city will fall,
and that’s only the beginning.
The last episode is reducing
all 40 episodes
to the primal conversation of a mom
who didn’t get a chance to mother,
and a child who didn’t have
a mother to mother her.
Will they be able to find balance?
And if they can’t,
everything is going to fall apart.
Not only what’s in the house,
but the whole world.
A world out of balance
is a world of endless suffering,
unless you choose to end it.
Ultimately, Leanne has to make
a very difficult choice
to help this family and the world.
It’s a beautiful thing, that the domestic
story of a shattered family
and this biblical story
of this dark entity
meet in this storyline
of a mother and a daughter.
What was really interesting,
when I look back on it,
because I didn’t think of it
as my story only,
there was a little bit
of distance that I had from it
that allowed me to be very loose
with my storytelling,
in a way that I’ve never been able to do.
I felt, to some extent,
I was following the muse in my head.
I had all these amazing writers
and directors to help tell the story.
I got to work with an incredible
group of storytellers
that I normally wouldn’t have gotten
a chance to tell stories with.
You will distinctly feel
each filmmaker’s hands,
and why episode 401
is really different than the second one,
which is really different
than the third episode.
And they’re very different
than my episode,
but it’s all one family of language.
And I do think celebrating
our differences in our voices and artistry
will make Servant have deep,
deep resonance.
It’s 40 little films that were directed
by these incredible storytellers.
-And cut!
-Cutting.
All right, great. Check it.
Servant, I think, forever will be
a magical experience for me.
It is something that we had got to do
with such purity, in such an unusual way.
When we got to the last episode,
and we said goodbye
to the cast and the crew,
it was super emotional,
because we know this is rare.
To have this much love
and artistic integrity
in something, in the industry,
is very, very rare.
-And cut!
-Cutting.
I just wanted to thank you guys
for everything.
I got to do this in a way, with people
I love, at the highest level,
and, you guys, you just…
I just can’t thank you enough.
It'll always be one of my most
cherished memories.
And I want to thank my amazing cast.
Love you all. You’re all family.
I went to the set for the very last time,
and I stood there and looked around.
I did take one or two pictures.
The set's getting torn down.
It’ll never exist.
We’ll never tell that story again.
I know one day I’m going
to be walking and just start weeping,
because I don’t know
how it could happen again,
to have that magic that bonded us all.
My hope is that Servant
will be watched for years to come.
I want it to be meaningful
and stick with you.
Having had this
artistically pure experience,
that Apple allowed me to have,
I’m so grateful.